So I'm about to start a movie Marathon with my kids and my family,
and all I wanna do is just, like,
hide in a hole. I did get out last night
and got to socialize with some other like minded individuals
here in Charleston. And the event was like an influencer thing,
but it was the. The vibe was somber.
Like we were all just looking at each other,
checking in on each other,
you know? And those are the people
and those are the circles that I am seeking out right now,
because I can't not think or talk about what has happened.
I am still processing all of my anger and disappointment and sadness,
um,
about the election, and I don't know how long that's gonna take
until we're business as usual.
I mean, I know I can't sit in here in this, like,
weird, shocky headspace for much longer.
I mean, we've got kids,
we've got life, the world keeps turning,
that sort of thing. Like,
we're gonna keep going one day at a time.
But I do know that I'm just emotionally
not great. Not great.
And I think the thing that I'm really sitting with
and trying to reconcile in my head
is knowing how many people wanted this
and having to reconcile my brain that I might have had this, like,
inflated view of who we are as a nation and what we value.
And I was wrong, at least for right now.
I think a lot of buzzwords scared a lot of people.
I think a lot of issues that were either media made up
or media exploited. Um,
things that aren't real threats to our democracy,
things that aren't real threats to your children
have been made into talking points
that have rallied a great deal of people
who do, in fact,
just want their kids to be safe.
I just don't think trans kids are as big of a threat to my kid
as your right to own an assault rifle.
And never have I ever
heard of a trans woman assaulting somebody in a bathroom.
But I digress. Because I live in Charleston.
I am kind of insulating right now.
I'm turtle shelling
because I'm not at a point where I can talk to somebody
and hear the devil's advocate
and hear the policies that they really liked
or have a civil conversation about why they voted for Donald Trump.
I'm just not there yet. I am in the anger, disappointment,
sadness, rage part of the grieving process.
And until I'm not, that kind of feral,
could snap version of myself,
I'm going to be, hmm, insulating.
Although me and my husband
plan to take the kids to a barbecue festival this weekend.
Um, that was, like,
before the election,
and now I'm realizing it's gonna be like a star spangled Celebration
high five experience. So
I don't know. It's weird.
It's weird living in the south.